[Musique]
bonsoir à toutes bonsoir à tous merci
d'être avec nous sur TV 78 nous sommes
le mercredi 3 janvier voici le programme
de ce soir 4re jeunes de trappe vont
rencontrer le pape François au Vatican
Lucas Angéline Cléa et Dylan vont
pouvoir bénéficier d'une audience privée
demain matin pour lui parler de la
situation dans les banlieux françaises
une initiative suite aux émeutes
urbaines qui ont éclaté fin juin en
France c'est l'une des grandes
nouveautés de l'année 2024 les jeunes de
17 ans peuvent désormais passer leur
permis de conduire une mesure permettant
aux adolescents de se déplacer et
d'entrer dans la vie active plus
facilement Elise et sukaina deux
habitantes de Montini le Bretonneux
comptent bien en profiter enfin du sport
dans votre 78 jusqu'au 7 janvier le
vélodrome national de Saint-Quentin en
nieline accueille les championnats de
France de cyclisme sur piste une
compétition importante qui permettra aux
meilleurs athlètes de prendre leur
marque sur la piste olympique à
l'approche des Jeux de Paris 2024 nous
serons notamment avec Benjamin Thomas
médaillée de bronze au giio de Tokyo
voilà pour le programme de ce soir mais
tout de suite je vous propose de faire
le point sur les inf information à
retenir aujourd'hui dans les
ivelines la tempête ANK se poursuit
Météo France recommande de rester
attentif aux dangers éventuels provoqués
par les intempéries les ivelines ont été
placé en vigilance jaune pour les vents
et les orages des rafales devraient
souffler à plus de 80 kmh et la foudre
pourrait frapper entre MIDH et 21h en
fin de matinée les pompiers éelinois
n'avaient pas noté de pic de sortie ces
conditions ont débuté hier la mairie de
Versailles avait choisi de fermer ses
parcs et ses jardins 12 jeunes
catholiques issus des quartiers
populaires des ivelines du valdoise et
de saintand vont rencontrer le pape
François parti pour Rome depuis hier ils
s'en tiendront demain avec le
représentant de l'Église chrétienne
parmi eux quatre trapistes une rencontre
provoquée par la mort de Naël à nanter
en juin 2023 ces jeunes croyants ont
pour ambition de montrer une image plus
solidaire des quartiers populaires
j- 205 avant le lancement des jeux
olympiques et paralympiques 2024
laabélisé terre de jeux 51 iveline
accueillera 5 épreuves du 28 juillet au
11 août et du 28 août au 8 septembre
cyclisme sur piste VTT golf BMX Race et
paracyclisme sur piste à l'occasion de
ce début d'année Sky entre en jeu pour
ne rien rater vous pouvez retrouver
toutes les informations relatives aux
épreuves sur le site Sky et les jeux et
si vous souhaitez également de devenir
bénévole sur l'événement vous avez
jusqu'au 15 janvier pour vous inscrire
sur le
site des conducteurs plus jeunes bientôt
sur les routes depuis le 1er janvier
2024 ceux qui ont 17 ans peuvent
désormais passer le permis de conduire
une mesure que les ivelinois voient d'un
bon œil Maxence de laacroué et Clara de
Frutos se sont rendus dans une
auto-école à Montini le
Bretonneux très bien et on prendra à
gauche s kenard conduire avant sa
majorité ce sera désormais possible
depuis le 1er janvier 2024 les
adolescents de 17 ans peuvent conduire
dès l'obtention du permis B auparavant
il était possible de l'obtenir avant sa
majorité grâce à la conduite accompagnée
mais il fallait attendre 18 ans pour
pouvoir conduire en toute liberté cette
liberté et cette autonomie c'est ce que
souhaitent sukaina et Elise toutes les
deux élèves dans cette auto-école à
montinil Bretonneux ça permet de
d'ouvrir des portes même ça nous permet
d'être plus autonome des très jeunes
notamment pour le sport ou euh pour
aller voir ma famille qui habitent pas à
côté je pense que ça peut être pratique
et euh de pouvoir y aller sans forcément
déranger l'un de mes parents ou de
prendre les transport j'en profiterai
parce que enfin j'ai ça permet de
libérer d'une certaine façon mes parents
euh parce que vu que j'ai un lo de temps
assez chargé ça permettrait de de les
laisser un peu plus euh eu avoir du
temps cette mesure
l'avantage aussi de nombreux parents qui
n'auront plus besoin d'accompagner leurs
enfant presque majeur ça va m'alléger
dans le sens où elle va pouvoir bah
conduire toute seule ou j'aurais plus
besoin de l'emmener à droite à gauche
elise a énormément de d'activités donc
il est vrai qu'à partir du moment où
elle va être autonome ça ça va nous
permettre d'être d'être plus autonome et
et de me laisser plus de liberté autant
qu'elle que moi pour Sandi des Maré
monitrice à Montini le Bretonneux cette
mesure laisse place à quelques
questionnements notamment ce qui
concerne les délis de passage du permis
de conduire c'est une crainte dont on a
tous beaucoup parlé dans la profession
les élèves vont nous demander de passer
leur permis en direct un peu plus
rapidement on nous a certifié au niveau
du ministère notamment par une note que
il y a des déblocages d'inspecteurs en
mars prochain l'auto-école prévoit déjà
d'accueillir un nouveau moniteur pour
répondre à la demande mais les élèves
doivent aussi anticiper leurs
inscriptions on leur a demandé
d'anticiper d'anticiper un petit peu
plus sur leur formation de façon à ce
que au 2 janvier ils s'attendent pas à
passer leur permis dès le 2 janvier mais
qu'on puisse étaler toutes leur
formation comme il faut à 17 ans les
adolescents titulaires du permis de
conduire resteront pénalement
responsables en cas d'accident mais la
responsabilité financière reviendra aux
parents tant qu'ils n'auront pas atteint
leur majorité allez c'est le l'URE à
présent de passer aux invités du
[Musique]
78 dès demain et jusqu'au dimanche 7
janvier le vélodrome national de
Saint-Quentin en Eveline accueille les
championnats de France de cyclisme sur
piste une compétition importante juste
avant les Jeux olympiques de Paris 2024
Michel elmidero et Patrick Jacques de
dismu se sont rendus sur place quelques
heures avant le top départ regardez nous
sommes au Vélodrome national de 50 ans
en ivine à partir de ce jeudi 4 janvier
il y aura les championnats de France sur
pis jusqu'à ce dimanche 7 janvier à mes
côtés Nicolas André qui est responsable
événement à la Fédération française de
cyclisme et Benjamin Thomas qui a gagné
CIN titres de champion du monde bonjour
Alors Benjamin comment vous vous sentez
à quelques jours du début de l'épreuve
même ça sera demain bah pour nous c'est
un peu la la reprise la rentrée des
classes voilà on est on est en tout tout
début de saison donc c'est les les
premiers efforts et ça permet de de bien
lancer la saison juste avant les les
championnats d'Europe qui seront la
semaine prochaine c'est un rendez-vous
important pour vous ouais c'est un point
de passage important pour voilà
retrouver un peu les les efforts de la
piste après un hiver où on a fait on a
fait pas mal de routes donc donc voilà
c'est un point de c'est un point de
passage important et un bon pour le bien
pour le début de saison Nicolas André
c'est un événement important aussi pour
la Fédération Française de Cyclisme
c'est championnat de France oui c'est
c'est un événement très important sous
l'impulsion de Florian Rousseau
directeur du programme olympique depuis
2 ans on a replacé ces championnats
nationaux pour les élites au mois de
janvier euh un peu comme discipline
hivernale et comme l'a dit Benjamin
c'est très important pour pour ce début
de saison ils enchaînent avec les
Europes et on a à peu près 200 jours des
épreuves olympiques dans ce même
Vélodrome donc la Fédération tenait à
alimenter le ce qu'on appelle le Home
advantage et donc qu' puisse faire une
dernière répétition sur sur ce vélodrome
en compétition et aussi qu'on attire un
peu le le public qui aura peut-être pas
la chance d'avoir des billets Olympiques
pour venir les encourager qui sentent
que que toute la France est derrière eux
pour aller conquérir les titres si je
comprends bien c'est l'objectif de cet
événement c'est de monter en puissance
avant les Jeux Olympique c'est ça c'est
pas une répétition pour l'organisation
on a eu les championnats du monde en
2022 pour ça c'est une répétition pour
eux sur sur ce même Vélodrome ce même
parquet et pour la pour le public qui
sent que ben c'est une discipline qui
ramène des médailles chaque année euh
pour le sport français et j'espère que
ça va être encore le cas pour eux cette
année à la maison et donc c'est c'est
important pour la fédération de leur
offrir cet équipement pendant 4 jours
Benin Thomas qu'est-ce que ça vous fait
de voir toute cette équipe de France
réunie ici au Vélodrome national de 50
ans Nivine bah c'est c'est enfin c'est
bien on a on a un peu l'impression
d'être en stage un stage amélioré voilà
après il y a une forte
participation cette année je crois qu' y
il y a beaucoup de de séries de
qualifications dans chaque épreuve donc
ça montre vraiment que l'engouement et
puis euh et puis pour nous c'est bien ça
va faire voilà des des compétitions de
de haut niveau parce qu'il y a une
grosse denensité et et chaque épreuve
sera relevée quasiment sera quasiment le
niveau d'une d'une petite coupe du monde
donc nous c'est c'est super pour pour
travailler et et pour voilà comme comme
la Nicolas faire une répétition une
répétition générale alors vous vous
connaissez parfaitement ce vélodrome
national de 50 an vous avez même même
vécu à quelques kilomètres d'ici à
trrappe vous le connaissez parfaitement
ce ce vélodrome national 50 en est-ce
que quand même on continue à le
découvrir au fur et à mesure des
entraînements ici bah en fait on va dire
que les quand on a pas fait quand est
pas venu depuis plusieurs mois ouais les
premiers tours de piste on reprend des
nouvelles sensations mais après on
reprend on reprend très vite les repères
et c'est vrai qu'on on connaît cette
piste on connait cette piste sur le le
bout des doigts on en connait on connait
les les les virages les les lignes
droites et cetera donc c'est c'est
vraiment c'est vraiment notre notre
piste
et mais voilà après en course on a
toujours des sensation un peu différente
parce que il y a l'atmosphère il y a le
public et cetera donc on prend c'est une
piste où on prend beaucoup de plaisir
vous discutez peut-être entre pistard de
de cette piste des choses peut-être à
améliorer vous discutez un petit peu
entre vous ou pas bah il y a une grosse
recherche qui a été faite par le le le
le pôle performance de pour les pour les
Jos donc on est on a vraiment un
programme de développement axé sur que
ça soit les relet en américaine les
relais en poursuite par équipe les
trajectoires adopter il y a vraiment un
travail qui a été fait là-dessus on a
rien qui est laissé au hasard et et ça
c'est un petit avantage par rapport à
des nations qui qui ont seulement
disputé on va dire les les championnats
du monde ici ou les ou les championnats
d'Europe dans le passé nous on a
l'avantage de pouvoir s'entraîner ici de
tenter des choses de tester des choses
voir si ça marche et et arriver le jour
le jour J avec voilà ce petit avantage
ça peut être rien ça peut être quelques
diièmes mais ça peut faire la différence
sur sur des poursuites et on le peaufine
sur ce type de rendez-vous ouais ouais
on le peaufine ici en stage on le
travaille on le travaille on aura au
moins jusqu jusqu'au jeu qu à 5
rassemblements ici d'une semaine donc
donc on va on va pouvoir on va pouvoir
vraiment travailler dans des super
bonnes conditions Nicolas André
qu'est-ce que ça vous fait vous de voir
cette équipe de France ici réunie pour
ces ces championnats de France c'est pas
courant non c'est pas courant ça fait
plaisir hier on était en montage on a
anticipé très tôt parce qu'on savait qu'
qu'il venait s'entraîner une bonne
partie de de la matinée donc on voulait
pas les déranger euh ça fait plaisir
d'avoir les meilleurs on a 142 engagés
comme disait Benjamin on a une densité
assez forte pour ce championnat et on a
on a tous les meilleurs qui seront là
pour disputer 16 titres nationaux durant
ces 4 jours 10 pour les endurants et 6
pour pour les sprinters euh bah ça fait
plaisir et j'espère que ça fera plaisir
au public qui qui s'est mobilisé qui
sera présent sur sur les quatre journées
il y aura quasiment que des épreuves qui
seront aux Jeux Olympiques on est
d'accord c'est ça on a privilégié un
programme bien sûr avec avec toutes les
épreuves olympique au programme donc
quatre épreuves olympiques pour pour les
endurants et et trois pour pour les
sprinters euh ben le but c'est de
préparer les Jeux et donc c'est c'est de
leur offrir un programme qui va avec et
puis on espère qu'ils trouveront comme
le dit Benjamin les meilleures
sensations et monter cresendo en
puissance pour pour le mois d'août
comment on fait pour venir sur cette
épreuve si on n'a pas encore son ticket
dans le public hein bien sûr alors bah
les achats en ligne se font toujours he
sur l'espace de de la Fédération je
rappelle un tarif privilégés pour les
ctinois à 5 € tarif pour les licenciés
FFC aussi à 5 € gratuit pour les moins
de 12 ans et 15 € pour pour les autres
et il y a un pass weekend samedi
dimanche à 25 € il reste des places on
sera environ à à 1000 1000 spectateurs
surtout sur vendredi samedi mais il
reste de la place sur les 4 jours donc
venez nombreux les encourager ils ont
besoin de VOUS Benjamin l'a dit c'est
très important de se mettre en situation
de compétition avec les encouragements
avec le stress plus il y a de monde plus
il y a de pression et donc ben je compte
sur sur chacun pour venir les voir dans
cette belle prépar praration la nouvelle
tenue l'homogénéité de de cette équipe
de France qui va aller jusqu'à jusqu'à
Paris 2024 et il y aura des épreuves
avec du suspense ah oui oui ben Jamin a
dit il il y a de la concurrence donc
même on va dire pour pour ceux qui ont
les références qui qui vont bien ils
auront de l'adversité c'est ça qui qui
qui contribue à la préparation il leur
faut de l'adversité et il y en aura donc
venez venez observer tout çain Thomas un
petit mot pour ceux qui n'ont pas encore
réservé leur place pour ce rendez-vous
il y aura du spectacle oui forcément
voilà comme comme l'a dit Nicolas on va
d'habitude quand on est sur des
championnats on court un par nation là
on va être on va être en opposition et
le niveau en France est vraiment
vraiment relevé donc sur sur mes
disciplines en tout cas ce que je peux
dire sur l'Omnium et sur l'américaine il
y aura vraiment des des beau du beau
spectacle avec beaucoup de suspense et
des coureurs qui ont voilà envie de ont
des fourmis dans les jambes voilà les
les sélections aussi pour les jeux sont
battent leur plein donc on est on est
beaucoup de coureurs pour pas beaucoup
de place donc il il y a forcément de de
l'adversité et mais voilà ça c'est reste
de l'émulation positive et pour venir
voir du spectacle il y a il y a rien de
tel et puis c'est sur le weekend surtout
il y aura il y aura vraiment du public
et cetera de l'ambiance donc c'est si
les gens peuvent venir qui n'hésitent
pas et comment ça se passe justement
quand quand on est sur la piste sur des
des championnats de France comme comme
celui-là on dit a son copain qui est à
côté ou on y pense pas du tout on est
vraiment dans sa course oui on est dans
sa course après voilà on n'oublie pas
qu'on est quand même on est on est quand
même on est quand même collègue donc
c'est toujours on fait peut-être on est
peut-être un peu plus gentil on va dire
sur des des championnats notamment voilà
ouais on va on va éviter on va éviter ce
genre de choses principale c'est de
sortir de là avec avec une bonne
préparation et et être en pleine santé
après pour les pour les championnats
futurs et mais après voilà il y a pas de
il y a pas de cadeau à avoir et on est
là on est là pour pour se tirer la Bour
entre guillemets et pas se faire de pas
se faire de cadeau et se faire plaisir
et Nicolas Andr il y aura des
marseillaises tous les jours ici dans ce
blodrome national de C en liveline c'est
ça la particularité de la c'est qu'il y
a il y a beaucoup de spécialités donc
beaucoup de titres discernés comme j'ai
dit 16 et chaque jour ben on entendra
les Marseillaises et j'espère qu'elles
raisonneront jusqu'au mois d'août et
voilà parce que c'est c'est vraiment
l'objectif pour pour une fédération pour
des des sportifs qui qui qui se prépare
pour ça et donc ben ils ont à cœur de
briller dans 6 mois et et ben c'est la
répétition j'ai encore les frissons voir
l'ambiance du titre mondial de de
Benjamin dans notre dos là sur la ligne
d'arrivée il y a quelques mois et donc
ben on va essayer de faire perdurer
cette ambiance dernière question
qu'est-ce qu'on peut souhaiter vous
souhaitez à l'organisation pour cet
événement bah que le public soit au
rendez-vous ça contribue à la
performance et qui est comme l'a dit
Benjamin aussi pas de chute pas de chute
grave sur sur ce vélodrome que puisqueil
y a les Europes la semaine prochaine
donc ça soit sur le chemin de la
préparation on a toujours peur de des
incidents voilà en course et la piste
est une discipline quand même à risque
mais voilà on a les meilleurs ils
joueront pas complètement des coudes
même si l'adversité sera là et donc ben
voilà des tribune remplie pas de chute
et et des beau beaux vainqueurs en
pleine préparation pour pour les jeux de
paris merci à tous les deux c'est
championnat de France débute ce jeudi 4
janvier au Vélodrome national de 50 an
livvin et vous l'avez compris il reste
encore des places pour assister à
l'événement jusqu'à ce dimanche et c'est
bientôt la fin de cette émission mais
juste avant je vous propose de jeter un
coup d'œil à la météo de
demain demain matin les nuages seront
encore bien présent sur l'ensemble du
département seul le secteur de Mantel
jolie devrait avoir quelques éclaircis
au niveau des températures il fera 6°gr
à Houdan et rouillé et 7°gr à Versailles
et montelajolie durant l'après-midi pas
de grand changement le ciel restera
couvert côté température il fera 9° à
rambouiller oudans et versaill et 10°gr
à Montel jolie et demain nous fêterons
la saint au Dylon c'est la fin de cette
émission merci beaucoup pour votre
fidélité je vous souhaite une belle
soirée sur tv78 prenez soin de
[Musique]
vous